some quick hitters coming out of week
seven the
green bay packers have the houston
texans this week predict the aaron
rodgers headline after sunday's game
peter
uh rogers throws for four touchdowns a
racist nightmare of tampa
yeah i i uh
i'll tell you
i don't know that it's gonna be quite as
easy for the packers because i think the
texans maybe are a little bit better
than we realize their record makes us
think otherwise
um
but yeah this feels like one where
if it was a wake-up call then you're
awake right packers wake up i guess not
a really great headline not my best work
but then again i usually set a fairly
low bar but if it was a wake-up call
last week prove it to us prove it to us
that you can go on the road and win the
the challenge for the packers is when
they go play these teams that they don't
always see on the road it's one thing to
go and face division rivals but when
they have to go to
the chargers when they have to go to the
49ers look what happened to them last
year they go to the buccaneers look what
happened to them they're going to
houston a place they go once every eight
years
can they can they just properly focus on
the task at hand there's something there
it's such a contrast between how well
they otherwise play and when they get
into these
unusual unconventional not typical road
games
they they tend to maybe have some issues
and i think that's something i'm going
to be paying attention to but i still
think that they'll get it right wake up
call answered packers should get their
win um
here we go with uh the tampa bay
buccaneers and the las vegas raiders
whether it happens on sunday monday or
tuesday how about john gruden let's
listen to him on playing the buccaneers
for the first time since he returned to
coaching
just concentrating on this game honestly
it's a
great opportunity for both teams to
try to get another win but i try not to
get too deep too philosophical i had a
great time in tampa a lot of my best
friends are still there and lived there
so i'm looking forward to competing
yeah hopefully he gets to compete and
hopefully they get their guys under
control so they can properly uh comply
with what the nfl requires to keep
themselves healthy and to keep
themselves able to play what's the
bigger concern though assuming this game
goes off whether it's sunday whether
it's monday whether it's tuesday the
bigger concern for gruden is it the
buccaneers defense or is it dealing with
tom brady
his biggest concern far and away is
whether he's going to have his offensive
line you know that's got to be his
biggest concern because you saw
how imposing
the tampa bay defense was
against aaron rodgers and against the
packers
they didn't for the last three quarters
the packers could not breathe and and so
like to if i if i'm gruden
i'm i'm thinking i gotta have my
offensive line back i have to or else
it's gonna be a real ugly game for us
yeah it is going to be uh very ugly for
the raiders if they don't have their
starting offensive line against a
defense that is looking better and
better all the time for the tampa bay
buccaneers chiefs broncos now look it
depends upon where you look the forecast
that you get the dark sky app that i've
been using for years now says 7 to 11
inches of snow in denver on sunday
others say more like one to three either
way snow is in the forecast it would be
the second straight chief's broncos game
with snow last december in kansas city
they had snow so a chiefs broncos snow
game in october would be what peter
fitting
for this year in america
you know i was watching the nbc news
last night and they got a reporter in
billings montana at the hospital and
there's a snowstorm behind him you know
i said wow i mean the world series isn't
even halfway over and we're having snow
storms in the country
um look mike you know to me
i think the denver broncos
have one other task other than
finding out if they can if they can
stick with the kansas city chiefs
you know
that to me was
a weird weird game that they played in
foxborough
and i leave that game with a lot more
questions about drew locke
than i have answers about drew luck
because
you just can't throw the ball away twice
in the last six minutes the way he did
you just can't do it
he almost
gate handed the new england patriots the
game they're lucky that you know malik
reed and the guys on defense didn't
allow it to happen
but you know to me i
i really still have a lot of questions
about drew locke and
i wonder if if he has a so-so year
is john elway going to pick his 19th
quarterback now
you know
is he going to have a 19th attempt to
get the quarterback right in denver
and i don't i you know i don't know how
many more chances he's going to have if
lock's not the guy
hey and here's what vic fangio the coach
of the broncos said to me
after that win over new england 18 to
12. we've got to make good decisions he
can't just throw the ball up there in
the middle of the field and hope for a
good outcome uh not afraid to criticize
drew locke for throwing those two
interceptions that gave the patriots a
chance and the other thing too they got
to score touchdowns whether it's snowing
or not snowing they got to score
touchdowns against the kansas city
chiefs and the thing that fangio
realized is he addressed this yesterday
the possibility of snow we know what
patrick mahomes can do in the snow what
a story that is guy who
never played in the snow until the
divisional round of the playoffs in the
2018 season colts game nbc was there for
the game it's snowing and he's out there
before the game realizing i kind of like
throwing a football that has snow on it
i kind of like playing in these
conditions and that's what mahomes told
me after that game last year when they
beat the broncos in kansas city i like
it like this so it kind of plays into
the chiefs hands to get a snow game and
and if anything vic fangio and the
broncos should be hoping it doesn't now
dark sky has
reduced the projected total from seven
to eleven to three to seven but still
potential snow game in the forecast on
sunday in denver all right
buffalo
cleveland
no buffalo it's not buffalo cleveland
it's uh cleveland cincinnati builds jets
who bounces back more emphatically is it
the browns against the bengals or is it
the bills against the jets
the bills obviously because the jets are
the toledo mudhens
um i think the bengals are i think the
bengals are pretty good mike i think
that
uh this is not a
throw your helmets on the field game
for the cleveland browns uh i i just i
continue to be hugely impressed with joe
burrow he is such a competitor
i just love watching him play that it's
the play's never over and and all that i
i hope hey listen
mike i hope he doesn't become david carr
because he's a really really good player
and they got to find a way to put him
more in
you know bubble wrap uh in these games
but
look the the buffalo bills are not going
to have any trouble with the new york
jets nobody is this year
i feel like one of these weeks the jets
are just going to find a way to wake up
playing for just pride or just get lucky
like
just an early break
now it's not going to happen they got
three more games until the bye and it's
the bills the chiefs and the patriots
they're going to be 0 and 9. and i i
it's just it's just not i i feel bad for
everyone involved but they are at a
level that is so far below what's
acceptable for an nfl team it's
laughable it's sad it's beyond being
funny so what makes
what are they even doing
joe douglas needs to use the next week
forget about reading the back pages
which just totally tar and feather the
jets every single day
he needs to spend his next week trying
to get avery williamson and jamison
crowder trying to get draft picks for
those two guys and again i wrote last
week in my column that
jameson crowder ought to be part of the
long-term solution with the jets he
ought to be because he's a really really
good player but i just get the sense
from what i'm hearing that the jets are
more in tune
with trying to get as many draft picks
as they can heading into the next two
drafts probably the smart way of doing
business but if i was a team out there
i would want jameson crowder a team in
need of a receiver i'd want jameson
crowder a lot i think he's dangerous
uh you know he's got a hundred catches
in his last 16 games he's just he's a
really good football player um and
somebody could get a pretty good bargain
if they could get them for let's say a
four
peter i saw someone suggest yesterday
that they would take a second round pick
for quinn and williams the third overall
pick in the 2019 draft i mean this is
full-blown fire sale potential and it
should be they're not going to be
competitive they're not suddenly going
to start winning games and i say this
all along never go into a season with
the intention of tanking
but once you know
you've got no chance at the post season
why try to win games you only lose by
winning at that point and if you can
sell off all your best players guys who
aren't going to be there for the future
guys you've already made that decision
about don't wait until after the season
get what you can now and then you put
the backup in and you're even worse than
you were not that not that
this is a team that doesn't have to try
to lose but this is the point where you
just fold the tents on 2020 and you move
on
i that's what i do if i were joe douglas
and just try to get as much draft
capital as you can and not necessarily
to use all that draft capital you know
some of the smartest general managers
take a three this year and trade for a
two next year so
you know the jets right now have to be
all in on the future and at some point
they're gonna have to be all in on
convincing trevor lawrence to not pull
an eli manning of 2000
and you know one last point is that a
rabbit hole that we should go down or
not
yeah we'll we'll go down that rabbit
hole another time but just something to
keep in mind
with the jets by all appearances
throwing in the towel one of the big
concerns that the league has as these
teams fall out of contention will
everyone continue to dot every eye and
cross every t on covet 19 protocol
compliance that's one of the big
concerns because that lure of the post
season and knowing you're still playing
for something is what's going to keep a
lot of teams on the right side of the
protocols they're very concerned as
teams slip out of contention
will they have issues will they have
problems and at least in the nfc east
you can be bad but you're still in
contention last topic washington will
score at least blank points on the
cowboys peter what do you think
uh 27
and i think it'll be enough i think
washington wins that game i just think
it's going to be very hard for the
cowboys
offensive line to hold out a lot of
those high picks on defense and again
look
you know the one thing about uh the
washington
defensive front is that it has depth you
know that that that ryan kerrigan is now
basically the you know the third wheel
and he's still a really really good
player by the way
ryan carrigan is a guy who in my opinion
if i were seattle uh and if i were a
team that really wanted a pass rush for
the next year and a half that's it year
and a half that's it
i'd go i'd
try to get ryan kerrigan i'd i'd want to
trade something significant for him but
be that as it may i just think dallas is
not going to be able to hold out uh
washington's front seven
washington 30th in scoring averaging 18
points per game ron rivera said
yesterday that he is very big on gut
feeling when he makes decisions he
learned that from john madden after
rivera's first couple of seasons with
the carolina panthers and peter i think
this team could still contend in the nfc
east if ron rivera would develop the gut
feeling to go with alex smith instead of
kyle allen at quarterback and i keep
hoping that that would happen because he
might i think that's their last best
chance to try to pull their way back in
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports